Leute ist es nicht wunderschön hört ihr
die Kreissäge man merkt wir sind in der
off season hier wir haben dieses
wunderschöne Haus hier vorne gemietet
wir mussten es machen wir zeigen 350
Euro die Nacht für diese Fette Villa in
der man mit 8 Personen sein kann wir
sind jetzt zu sechs aber zu acht anderen
45 € pro Person ich zeige euch mal ein
bisschen was da abgeht weißt du es
wirklich so nice gibt euch den Ausblick
wir sind hier in der Nähe von Castella
Mare der Golf wo ist mein Traum die
Supermärkte das Essen und die Landschaft
das wird richtig geiles Video das
einzige was für diesen Urlaub bringen
einfach so ein bisschen Leben bei einem
Tag essen was wir halt zu essen ne guck
mal
hier vorne kommen wir zu einem
Aussichtspunkt und an dem steht schon
die ganzen letzten Tage so ein Truck der
Kanoni espress und alles was das Herz
begehrt verkauft da werden wir jetzt mal
hinfahren können wir die ganze Zeit
schon was da holen aber wir hatten nicht
so gutes Wetter wie heute heute ist der
Tag
guckt euch das an einen riesen Kanone
Ricotta Füllung Pistazie darüber man
hätte das auch mit Eis haben können ich
glaube so kann man perfekt und Kalorien
haben sein Tag starten
schön knusprig muss man mehr sagen
wir müssen einkaufen
[Musik]
das wirklich ein gefühlten drei
Seelendorf wo wir sind aber es ist nicht
schlimm weil das was wir hier suchen das
gute Essen das gute Leben das findet man
in jeder Ecke da muss man nicht
irgendwie in der Großstadt mit einer
riesen Auswahl sein sondern man muss
einfach nur in die nächste Bäckerei
[Musik]
Süßigkeiten drei Kaffee 11 € und schönes
Croissant mit pistazienfüllung
weil sich auswander bald ist einfach
geil wir haben die letzten Tage sehr
genossen wir wollen ganz viel Film wir
haben heute diesen einen Tag wo wir aber
auch einfach nur euch mitnehmen und
nicht irgendwie was aus der Reihe machen
oder so deshalb ist es ein sehr sehr
schöner Urlaub den wir hier gemeinsam
verbringen dürfen und dann umso
schönerer starte den Tag guck mal was
noch so kommt später gibt's leckere
Pizza
[Musik]
machen wir uns jetzt also eine schöne
Pasta und zwar gibt es Pasta bufalla mit
Pistazien crumble und Mozzarella ist ein
HelloFresh Rezept hello fresh
unterstützt auch dieses Video ich habe
dieses Rezept nämlich in Deutschland
schon mal gekocht wie das Ganze
vonstatten gegen zeige ich euch gleich
aber es war so gut dass ich es einfach
noch mal machen musste so deshalb habe
ich alles hier eingekauft und ich sage
euch so viel einer der Vorteile von
HelloFresh man muss nicht in einladen
für die Zwiebel in einladen für die
Pasta und dann noch mal los wenn man
Balsamico Creme vergessen hat kommt
einfach alles zu dir ganz entspannt nach
Hause bleibt unbedingt dran beim Rezept
weil es schreit einfach Italien habe ich
auch wirklich inspiriert und noch mehr
Freude auf diese Reise hier gemacht
deshalb viel Spaß dabei ich koche das
ganze und dann lass uns schmecken und
genau so kam das ganze bei mir an eine
Tüte kein einkaufstress gucken wir mal
was drin ist erster Vorteil hier drin
ist alles was wir brauchen und zwar eine
rote Zwiebel Pistazien Kräuterbutter
Knoblauch bei samichl Creme Büffel
Mozzarella Tomaten Basilikum und frische
Linguine klingt schon mal verdammt gut
und ich sage euch so viel ich glaube es
wird richtig lecker und das beste ist
das Rezept ist richtig einfach deshalb
legen wir los wir nehmen uns die
Pistazien und geben sie einmal hier in
die Pfanne rösten die ein bisschen an
bis sie duften dann herausnehmen etwas
abkühlen und pro packen Knoblauch gehabt
Basilikum Blätter in feine Streifen
schneiden das ist auch mal entspannt für
mich einfach mal ablesen einfach mal
eins zu eins nachgucken wie man es macht
einfach mal den Kopf ausschalten und ich
glaube genau so richtet sich HelloFresh
an viele Leute die stressigen Alltag
haben die nicht immer nachdenken können
oder wollen was Sie kochen müssen aber
trotzdem frisch kochen wollen trotzdem
mit frischen Zutaten arbeiten wollen zu
viel einmal den Basilikum runter nehmen
von Basilikum nur die Blätter die Steine
entferne ich habe hier ein Messer und
schneide ihn in feine Streifen ich meine
wenn man hier so die Farben sieht die
Aromen in der Küche riecht ich habe so
Bock auf dem Italien trifft kein Spaß
das wird so nice zumindest kulinarisch
sind wir heute schon da wir haben schöne
Streifen die trotzdem noch so eine
gewisse Struktur haben die können wir
dann am Ende einfach drüberlegen wenn
wir zum Garnieren brauchen wir als
nächstes ist das Herzen sind angeröstet
die gebe ich kurz hier aufs Brett und
direkt ein bisschen Oliven Höhe in die
Pfanne hinein darin schwitze ich jetzt
einmal die Zwiebel an aber keine Farbe
rangehen sondern nur glasig anschwitzen
jetzt hacke ich die einmal grob drüber
hacken generell das Farbspiel bei diesem
Gericht ist wirklich krank die Zwiebeln
sind angeschwitzt noch nicht allzu viel
Farbe ich gebe den Knoblauch hinzu das
sehen ein bisschen an und es folgen
unsere Tomaten Qualitätskontrolle aber
weitere vier bis fünf Minuten anbraten
bis die Kirschtomaten leicht aufplatzen
mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen
währenddessen Linguine in den Topf mit
kochendem Wasser 3 bis 4 Minuten bis
festkochen die Tomaten aus wenn Sie ein
bisschen aufgekocht sind jetzt geben wir
die Linguine ins kochende Wasser weil es
frische Nudeln sind brauchen die
vielleicht zwei maximal drei Minuten
bisschen Salz dran und während das hier
vor sich hinarbeitet kann ich euch zum
Beispiel sagen dass er noch fresh jede
Woche über 20 verschiedene Rezepte für
dich anbietet und alle sind so schön wie
diese was auch super praktisch ist in
deinem flexiblen Abo kannst du jederzeit
die Lieferung anpassen und oder
pausieren falls mal Besuch bekommst
kannst du auch die Portionsgröße
anpassen und ihr merkt schon das ist
alles maximal flexibel und anpassbar die
Lieferanten von HelloFresh sind lokal
und hochwertig die Lieferung erfolgt
klimaneutral und die Verpackung sind
recycelbar mit meinem Code hello Max
könnt ihr in Deutschland bis zu 90 €
sparen in Österreich bis zu 100 und der
Schweiz bis zu 140 Franken also auf
deine ersten vier Boxen und in deiner
ersten Box zahlst du wenn du für vier
Personen bestellst nur 2 € und 67 Cent
pro Person also ein Risiko dass man
eingehen kann wenn man das ganze mal
ausprobieren will ich kann Euch so viel
sagen die Rezepte haben mich noch nie
enttäuscht die Nudeln sind mittlerweile
fertig wir gucken mal wie es weitergeht
Fahrenheit mit Balsamico Creme und passt
da Wasser ablöschen und ein zwei Minuten
einköcheln lassen
Salz Pfeffer Zucker abschmecken
heute Mutter ist drin schmilzt langsam
hinein und jede Komponente hat verdammt
viel Geschmack und ich bin mir sicher
das wird ein köstliches Gericht jetzt
gehen wir die Nudeln dazu frische Pasta
auch schöne kauft man sich auch nicht
alle Tage da ist es cool oder so ein
Stoß in die richtige Richtung bekommen
ich merke schon das ist eine schöne
Menge Soße für unsere Linguine jetzt
amore wir müssen wir gar nicht mal nach
Italien Pfeffer und vor dieser
wunderschöne Pasta richten wir an tiefer
Teller Suppenkelle Pinzette drehen
platzieren auf Fächern Cherrytomaten bzw
Pistazien zupfte Büffelmozzarella und
Basilikum sind wir in Italien oder nicht
was für eine wunderschöne Pasta einfach
zubereitet alles kam zu mir nach Hause
deshalb vielen lieben Dank an HelloFresh
auch für die Unterstützung von meinem
Kanal wie sie schmeckt seht ihr jetzt in
Italien guckt euch diese Pasta an ich
weiß ja schon wie gut sie schmeckt aber
ich sage euch so viel das ist einfach
ein Traum deshalb vielen Dank nochmal an
HelloFresh dass sie dieses Video
unterstützt haben und dass sie mich
inspiriert haben zu diesem Gericht weil
das ist einfach geil probieren wir noch
mal mein Mann hat halt wirklich nicht
immer die Zeit oder die Lust so
aufwendig einzukaufen und man ist auch
nicht immer in Sizilien wo es die besten
Produkte frisch gibt es schon praktisch
wenn man sie sich einfach nach Hause
liefern lassen kann
so simpel so lecker einfach geil
cremiger Mozzarella Nudeln haben geilen
bis weil sie frisch sind Cherrytomaten
Säure frische einfach ein geiles Rezept
ich muss jetzt draußen die Sonne und den
abholen machen Freunde wir haben den
Nachmittag sehr entspannt hier im Haus
verbracht und ihr seht schon es wird
Zeit etwas Schönes zu grillen wir haben
eingekauft und es gibt wirklich
wunderbare Spezialitäten wir haben eine
family schon in den Ofen begleitet hat
hier vorne
angezündet ich baue jetzt gerade hier
das Nest damit das Feuer auch gut
angehen wird
[Musik]
mittlerweile sind wie viel Stunden
vergangen im 18:36 Uhr Mittagessen ist
auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen her
kurzes Story wenn man Video gedreht
einen Tag alles essen am Flughafen es
hat niemals das Licht der Welt erblickt
weil wir viel zu betrunken waren aber
ich habe das Gefühl heute schaffen wir
es ganz kurz was grillen wir haben hier
in der sizilianischen Abendsonne eine
wunderschöne ist lecker und schönes
fettes Steak mit Knochen vorbereitet
erik hat ein paar mit Joana gemacht das
heißt Sugo Aubergine ich habe das
gesehen vielleicht ein Video mit der
italienischen Oma
und Parmesan dass das krasse das kann
man hier in Italien einfach im
Supermarkt kaufen hey das sieht so schön
aus alter das ist an der Zeit Eric Clip
das Steak das wirklich ein Traum ist ne
700 800 Gramm
guckt euch das an wir haben noch mehr
Grillgut und die Besonderheit ist alles
kommt aus dem Supermarkt wir haben
einfach hier ist euch vorstellen quasi
ein aufgeschnittenes halbes Hähnchen du
hast hier den Hähnchenschenkel aber auch
Teil der Brust oder ist es einfach so
richtig nice schön flach auf den Grill
legen kann 1,2 kg 8 € wäre das nicht
kennt schaut euch mal an wie lange hier
die Würstchen sind sogar das hier das
ist schon das ist schon zu lang für
draußen
einfach so mit der Hand zack drin machen
wir noch einen frischen Salat gesagt
patate iphoneo aus dem Backofen und dann
können wir Essen bereiten jetzt alles
vor und dann sehen wir uns beim Abend
ist das hier ist die Ausbeute wir haben
eine wunderschöne Parmigiana von Eric
richtig ordentlich mit Käse bearbeitet
das fett schwimmt hier oben drauf
Parmigiana wäre es nicht kennt
Auberginenauflauf italienisches Weißbrot
dazu Hähnchen und ein wunderbares Steak
was ihr vorhin gesehen habt ein bisschen
Salat so kann man auf jeden Fall gehören
den Tag kulinarisch beenden wir haben
wirklich nur zu Hause gechillt am Pool
ein oder anderen Alkohol getrunken die
Kartoffeln ihr fragt mich vielleicht
warum haben die nicht gefilmt wie man
die zubereitet so kann man die kaufen im
italienischen Supermarkt das haben wir
getan einfach nur mein Ofen gehauen das
so wie in einem geilen Restaurant
perfekten Ofenkartoffeln so fettig weich
nicht so super knusprig aber braucht
keiner
boah probier mal meine Parmigiana
allererste fahren mit Jana meines Lebens
ich bin selber übelst gespannt noch nie
gemacht ist auch voneinander das Rezept
sehr gut
nehmt euch mal was von der herzhaft
fertig oder fertig sein Vater das ist
besser
von der besten Seite geile Produkte
gutes Wetter leckeres Essen das braucht
man mehr wir hatten ich hoffe ihr könnt
das mitverfolgen ein wunderschönen Tag
die führen wir ihn zu Ende es bleibt
offen falls wir uns nicht mehr sehen
wünsche ich euch einen wunderschönen Tag
bleibt sauber
soll ich zeig dir in den Ausblick noch
mal zum Ende
was passiert
Haselnuss dunkler Schokolade Schokolade
Pistazie Mango Erdbeere Zitrone